a lot of opportunities are popular
enough in the cloud computing domain
which simply learns Cloud architect
Masters program I was able to have such
an opportunity with a 60 percent salary
height I feel that I am finally on the
right track in my career okay I live in
Delhi with one family thanks change
drastically when the covid-19 pandemic
hit I was working with system link
for which
thought upstream was necessary I
observed that cloud computing was a
blooming thing I knew that age of the
2050 were in huge demand so in 2020 I
decided to upskill myself with Cloud
architect Masters program
simple and provide job assistance
programs in cloud computing for that I
thought it would help me to change my
domain and plan a job at that time
lockdown was built I was working from
home so I decided to localize my time
now I am very happy that I did soon
after I completed the course I landed a
job with Calpine Solutions private
limited as login Gmail with a 60 percent
salary height
it was what I had in my mind
I really like the AWS solution for
Cricket classes by our instructors are
the being in technology sector you have
to keep up Skilling and learning new
stuff I got married last year and I
tried my best to take out time to travel
around with my wife also I read a lot of
psychological and motivational books to
keep myself motivated I feel that you
can pass through any difficult times if
you keep yourself motivated and updated